petit l'avant des pc saison 2 sais tu
parles je pense que toutes les séquences
commence par ces partis quand tu vois
c'est un petit club
c'est parti quand tu veux quoi ont la
double quand tu veux vraiment là on est
sur un tic verbal
elle salue robin j'ai commencé le hockey
allez c'est parti action
c'est parti alors et konami code c'est
quoi déjà
je le dit convaincu que touchent les
sens je voulais te dire bah oui bah oui
heureusement que fabrice luchini ses
acteurs et parties balle au bond et
doucement hu a été fait
cette contre-indication fake regarde et
attitudes félicité j'ai bavé comme un
porc bah écoutez cette pro stock ne sont
parfaitement normales
allez vas-y non c'est marrant de voir
tous les sols on en trouve aussi dans le
cul romain vitiello bien au fond à
droite
[Musique]
j'espère tout le monde
monaco a alors étudié pour abonnés via
la dtcc fini pour aujourd'hui vous allez
tous crever alors faites pas chier dix
camions
j'ai un peu honte de ses blagues ça
tourne toujours
[Musique]